hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey we are going to watch from
the warp zone Captain America's life
after endgame one can only predict how
that went down I hope it's like the
story the script I wrote called warp
zone back in sixth grade star to you and
me we were brothers it was like sci-fi
and you know who's gonna be I didn't
really work out the the plot alright
let's watch this if you don't have a
story don't bring it up John there was
the one about the guy gets sucked into
his recycling can that has to nevermind
[Music]
it's Blanc ease of playing the Dodgers
in the World Series you're gonna tell me
who hit me okay you know I can't do that
come on you can't even give me a date
seriously honey we've talked about this
my mission was to return all the
Infinity stones the exact time and
places that we got them into yet if I
were to tell you anything about the
future no matter how insignificant it
might seem it would change the history a
whole new future I know this meet your
new grannies Sharon Carter Oh God
not even a little bit
[Music]
everything all right now see I can't
shake the feeling something is going on
in this shield it's like some nefarious
group is hiding right under our noses
pulling the strings but God looks good
purpose it almost feels like I'm back in
the war and Hydra is laughing about it
what that's so crazy you wouldn't happen
to know anything about this you know
baby or salad oh because not only with
that forever tarnish my legacy and ruin
my life's work but it could also put
millions of innocent people's lives eat
steak steak that's what the Saudis stick
see Steve Walters you look at me yes yes
thank you
stiva heaviness world here's how would
you restock me just killed in a car
crash now that my retirement is
finalized I think it's time for us to
invest our little nest stay in the
market I've narrowed it down to these
two new Internet companies Amazon or
went bad which do you think see
whichever you feel dear you're right my
instincts you please serve me well with
vanities could push to kind of just flip
that coin or the Amazon I feel like they
haven't taken a trip in ages what do you
say we go up to New York next week and
pull the tower
sounds good honey when you want to go I
was thinking we'd meet
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
see why it's necessary nobody my family
has ever had that that moment we shared
where I was like yeah so I come in
you're like just the fact that she said
this specific world I think that
encapsulates what is great about this
sketch isn't it's just one repetitive
joke that's got a hundred percent
predictable as long as you know history
but it's in the little new scripted and
how the actors did it that yeah really
brought this to life
I was lost in that I might just started
going this whole idea with Captain
America doing what he did at the end of
endgame has just raised so many
questions so many questions they just
don't stop coming up and then whenever I
see these spoof sketches from how it
should have ended from how to cap get
the stones back then this of how he
lived his life with Peggy Carter knowing
all these things that would happen and
I've heard that art even that wouldn't
that go against caps whole philosophy
you who makes him him what makes his
core if he does also be around to he
could just stop more events letting all
this stuff happen we've got a character
thing to to pick here is if this was a
real thing that went on the MC this is
camp with the whole choice of Amazon was
the other one Hurley don't want you got
her though on yeah that's gonna be like
Apple or something yeah I like the idea
that she's like he knows which one's
gonna be successful yeah
not the choice of choosing Amazon or one
that no one's ever heard of is a great
call because you'd like well clearly
Amazon's the winner yeah yeah it's like
good riding to do that either way even
if that is just the reality of it so but
in that moment I was like well Peggy
never had this life with Steve Rogers
before so does it matter if she did they
end up choosing Amazon like can't he
just push her in that direction would it
really matter if she did that I don't
know what else does it affect what is a
what else you like about her to invest
in Amazon to you know that would be a
really interesting what if movie were
it's basically like Peggy and Steve's
trying to contain it trying to be like
okay only we will know and we will at
least use the the parts that won't
drastically affect the world to our
advantage and how hard that could be I
feel you could do such a cool what if
story with him knowing what's gonna go
on he lets a few things happen then
after a while it just starts to drive
him mad to the point where he has to do
something and he tries to prevent a very
specific real world historical event
that would be cool like Nomad story you
want some Marvel rewriter you're
watching warp zone that being said this
is a great great sketch first off I do
notice the font that you guys use for
the time for the years it's very
reminiscent of the Russo brothers choice
of font for the Captain America Civil
War the idea of how it starts off with
historical events and then tying it in
with shield or MCU timeline events I
thought was very clever is there's one
tragedy after another yeah oh here's
something that's gonna affect the MCU
that would have been really nice to know
about because yeah aliens we're gonna
lose something down the line because
Steve Gunn's begun the idea of how he's
avoids things with the salad and the
steak and did have no where at the end
he just has the sandwich yeah yeah yeah
I mean I always appreciate just a good
running like switch out the the prop gag
you know yeah it just gets whackier and
whackier mashed potatoes is a good call
it's such a simple idea of a sketch but
who thought provoking if you're super
into the MCU and the thing is I think it
works as well as it does because you
would have to imagine that they would
have to get into this experience a lot
like yes
many things that would happen
theoretically that yeah he would have to
keep quiet so much what do you want to
go on the 11th of September the weird is
like you they get there and you're like
oh I don't know there's something about
the way they handle this joke yeah there
really gets its point across like it's
funny I hadn't thought about it until we
watched how cap returned the stones
I just haven't like put that much time
into deconstructing that and now since
then all I can think about when it comes
to the MCU is like how does this even
work at this video is static to them
it's like I just wanted to believe cap
and Peggy live happily ever after now I
can't well yeah I mean it's because
there's so much that goes against yeah
Captain America's code yeah especially
with all Hydra bit to like it Bucky and
uh unless of course that's the dilemma
that that comes into play here other to
Steve Rogers basically on the same
timeline on the same timeline yeah is
there a Steve Rogers that went under the
ice and then wakes up in 2012 and by
this point that Steve Rogers is now an
old dude but then how does that explain
like has this Steve Rogers and Peggy
Carter relationship just been secret no
one all these years decades
no one has okay yes like no one has you
know it is no Captain America he is with
him it just raises all kinds of
questions and it's not about the details
and if it's supposed to be a fairy tale
yeah it's to be the fairy tale ending
and it's about the it's about the
feeling that it emits that end game
ending and I'm so on board for it and in
the moment of every time I've seen
endgame I I adore the [ __ ] out of that
ending I do want yeah I adore it but
then knowing that Marvel has this whole
thing with time travel and timelines and
know what it's you go well how exactly
is this work yeah you kind of gotta
ponder and I think what's cool is it
throughout this we can fantasize about
some cool storytelling I can go on it's
also but it's um hilarious a sketches
yeah right for comedians to pick a part
well this was special warp zone guys
subscribe to the warps
channel click that notification I really
love this roof oh yeah Lance story this
is a topper warts here video requests I
don't know if I mention that this is no
hands door who just got engaged
Oh land he sent me I asked him to send
me a video of it
I don't know if I couldn't put it up
here if I said I he did it
he proposed to his girl in front of the
Eiffel Tower this perfect shot with the
Eiffel Tower in the background she
didn't see it coming oh you didn't see
that coming now they're engaged you know
you got him finally you got yourself
your own Peggy Carter Dan having it on
Peggy Carter I would say now that you're
gonna marry her
peg her harder that's your wedding gift
oh man you sure you should Skype in
front speech come on annex peg her heart
Lance door is a Lance [ __ ] for your
love why hasn't the warp zone invited us
I to tell right for know my great ideas
these this is what I want yeah Lance
returns to stuff witty clever